يا اخوتي واخواتي الكرام عدنا لكم من جديد
معكم عبود 27 نوفمبر لنبدا
حلقتنا بدنا نبد لكم بالترتيب اليوم الع
على انقطاع الانترنت او الاكثر مش عارف
اكثر من 20 يوم على انقطاع الانترنت على
شمال القطاع وعلى كل قطاع غزه مش عارف
والله هذا اول شياني شي اهلنا بالجنوب ما
بنعرف عنهم شي اقسم بالله يعني مش عارف
اهلنا واخواتنا وكل الدنيا اهنا بال
الجنوب ما بنعرف عنهم شي تمام يعنينا لاث
اسابيع مش قادرين نلهم ولا احكي معهم لانه
ممنوح حد يروح على الجنوب ولا ممنوح حد
يجي على الشمال قصه ثاني شيء او ثالث شيء
مش ذاكر انه اللي قوات الاحتلال ارتكبت
الالاف من المجي زير بحق المدنيين والبيوت
وكل الدنيا فاهمين يعني اهلنا شمال ماقدرش
نروح لهم لانهم زلين الدور زي ما هي
بتلاقيها في نص الشارع مش بس يعني انا
بحكي عن الناس قصفوا دارنا دارنا من فوق
زل لك الصاروخ في المطبخ تقول رايح يعمل
شاي بس الحمد لله جت بسيطه يعني ما راحتش
كل الدار نفسها وهي الدنيا قاعده بتشتى
والناس في الشارع بدون ماوى ولا حاجه
واحنا حلقنا حلقه الشهاده انا والمصور ق
كيف وجي زي الكريك بعدين بنسخن ميه بد
نتحمم والوضع اي سكف على الاخر والسلام
عليكم